it's great to be joined today by Bethany
lishchyna who's an associate professor
of political science at the University
of Rochester she is an expert on ethnic
conflict and war and today we are going
to talk about how do we even get into
this topic Bethany I mean I guess for
your information last week I interviewed
former NFL running back Arian Foster who
was no longer in the NFL but was was
very involved with a lot of the players
who participated in the kneeling
national anthem protests that became
both a political and social and
pop-culture issue for a period of time
now that we've gotten like a little bit
of distance from the start of that
incident are we able to start analyzing
what the impact was of those protests in
terms of the players and the audience
and the NFL yeah I think the moment when
the impact was largest has probably
happened and now we'll see kind of how
the effects fade is they fade if
additional complications happen and so
on
so let's move the effect on people
watching football right in terms of this
dissuade people overall and then we
would of course have to break it down
and see how many people were more
interested in football as a result of
these protests but what do we know about
in the net what the effect was on on the
football audience from the protests so
we know a lot of people told pollsters
they were angry at the NFL and something
like there was something like a ten to
fifteen percent drop in the number of
Republicans and independents who said
they were NFL fans and we know that
around the same time the NFL was taking
a ratings hit it is a relatively cheap
thing to do to tell a poll or you know
easy thing to do to tell a pollster oh
yeah I'm not watching the NFL anymore
how many people really stuck with that
is hard to know the year-over-year
decline in watching the NFL has all
kinds of problems you know people who
dislike the way the rules have changed
the gameplay and so forth and the
decline of cable is it's the biggest
thing so it's too strong to say that the
whole ratings hit that the NFL took was
because the protests at the time Donald
Trump was taking advantage in his tweets
of the fact that the NFL had been
experiencing a ratings decline for some
period of time even before this incident
he was very conveniently attributing it
to people angry about the kneeling
protests but we do sort of have to
balance this against the fact that there
has been a decline in NFL ratings more
generally as well don't we yes and also
has nowhere to go but down it's insanely
popular so the taking taking a modest
hit means still being insanely popular
so it's been declining slightly from an
astronomical peak so let's now get into
some of the racial divisions that have
become clear based on the data when it
comes to the NFL in terms of perceptions
not only by white and non-white fans but
of white and non-white players what's
sort of the best entry point to start
talking about what the data suggests
there well I we we've known for a while
that white and black Americans have very
different views about whether the
protests were appropriate but and we've
known that there's a kind of diffused
anger at the NFL as a brand but when I
was
about is how does this translate into
how people are really relating to the
product on the field which is which is
ultimately the players and how do they
how are they feeling about the players
when they're not being asked a question
that sort of prompts them to think about
the anthem protests in light of not now
kind of reminding them that this is
something that's going on so what I've
been looking at is consumer data that's
been collected for four years not
because of the protests or anything else
but because companies want to pick
celebrities as spokespeople and looking
at just as the popularity of the players
changed when people are not thinking
about the protests in particular just
being asked you know how do you feel
about this this guy versus that guy and
when you did um there are 43 people who
marketers have been tracking from 2015
before the protest started to 2018 the
most recent data we have and you can
look at how did the comparisons between
these exact same people change and what
you find is that the in this group of 43
all of the people who participated in
the protests are black
the popularity of protesting players
fell in the general population and
particularly with whites but the most
important finding is that among whites
without a college education who are kind
of the base of the conservative part of
America black players lost popularity
relative to white players even if they
weren't protestors so there was a kind
of increase in resentment of black
players in general among the most
conservative part of the population okay
so let's see if we can sort of summarize
that in
sense players who are black have are now
less popular compared to before the
protests started but even the players
who didn't participate in the protests
but are black also were affected by this
decline in popularity yes right and is
it fair to say that that is particularly
marked with white viewers of the NFL yes
or at least with whites in general
viewers of the NFL it's tricky since now
people are you know telling pollsters oh
I don't watch this right among black
Americans there's essentially no change
in how they feel about these NFL stars
there's maybe a slight uptick in
popularity for Colin Kaepernick in
particular but black Americans just are
kind of holding steady in their ratings
of these players and white Americans are
reacting negatively to the protests and
then by extension feeling resentment of
some black players just in general how
about with regard to white players so
has the perception by either white or
non-white people voters of call them
voters or NFL viewers whatever you want
to call them has their perception of
favorability towards white players
changed before and after the kneeling
protests stairs ironically it's actually
easier to know how people are changing
relative to each other and to know how
they're changing in absolute terms for
the following reason the marketers who
collect this data or not sir they're
only interested in popular people so
somebody's popularity really plummets
they just get dropped from the survey so
how people feel about all white players
in general is is harder to suss out than
to know that okay for these 20 white
players their popularity has held steady
or gone up relative to these specific
black players can we say that is there
this cohort of white players who seemed
to have been unaffected by these
popularity shifts as a result ordering
so they're 20 years
I think they're 21 white players in the
data they're the stars of the NFL and
their popularity you know some of them
take it up a little some of them take
down a little they obviously have been
doing better and worse on the field but
as a group their popularity has not been
him so last week when I spoke to former
running back Arian Foster he said that
there were his perception and this was
not a scientific study but his
perception is someone in the NFL was
that the overwhelming majority of the
black players felt strongly in favor of
the protests when they were going on but
many said they are not going to get
involved they are going to stay silent
because they saw their involvement as a
potential liability a liability that
could be related to their relationship
with the owners and management of the
teams potentially in terms of their
relationship with the NFL but also with
how they are perceived with fans it
sounds like they were correctly
assessing that there would have been
consequences on the basis of the data
you're discussing here yeah there's no
question um and this this marketing data
has real consequences for people there
you know millions of dollars in
endorsements
licensing that turn on polling like this
how popular is this guy who do I want to
sell my cereal and the choice to protest
cost people and then it's also true that
black players took a hit to certain
extent regardless of their choice right
we see that even even those not
participating were negatively affected
waiting can you explain that in a little
more detail so there's this thing called
a cue score which is kind of like a
popularity score given by fans to
players how what are the ways in which
that translates into money for the
players I mean it's obvious if you're
more popular you'll be more in demand
for endorsements but what are some of
the other ways I think the owners would
claim that the decisions about actually
being on a team are not tied to
popularity though at the margin wanting
more popular players is makes sense I
think though there's people have
documented that just in general there's
there's there's tons of little ways in
which black athletes get presented to
the public differently they get
different media coverage they get
scouting reports that emphasize that
they're great athletes as opposed to
being intelligent
there's just a kind of accumulation of
little dings that add up to less money
in endorsements and licenses while
you're a player and then less money if
your autobiography less speaking fees
down the road less likely to get tapped
to
be talking head on a sports program
the kind of lifetime earnings of an NFL
player are not just about playing the
game they're also about just being liked
by the fans and there are lots of little
ways in which black players have a have
a tougher road there yeah I mean
particularly when the average career is
so short so much of it is what is it
that is available to you after after you
are not playing anymore we've been
speaking with Bethenny lishchyna who's
an associate professor of political
science at the University of Rochester
Bethany thanks so much for talking to us
today sure my pleasure